I can't see any of this I can't see the
mountain top of a yawning chasm in front
of me and this isn't some magical drone
camera hovering out in midair this is
the mixed reality lab at YouTube space
New York and if you want to see anything
around me other than these green walls
I'm going to have to wear this headset
the challenge with virtual reality is
that while the person who's in it is
amazed in waving their arms around and
experiencing it the rest of us don't
know what's going on and so mixed
reality is a way of letting everyone
else see what it would be like if we
were there too we have an actual camera
that is filming you in the headset in
front of a green screen and then the
game just needs to know where the
virtual camera should be we're using an
HTC vive for the VR and if we use a
third-hand controller and attach that
controller to the camera now the game
understands where the camera is and so
we can have both the actual camera and
the virtual camera moving through the
space and recording what it would be
like if we were inside there with you in
our kit we're using a PC that's specked
out with the highest end Intel processor
32 gigs of ram and the current high
level consumer video card which is an
NVIDIA GTX 1080 we're rendering at 4k
and anything less than that is going to
run into an issue what's needed to make
the mixed reality work is a small config
file that sits right in the root folder
of the game that you're playing and that
config file contains the offset between
where that controller sits and where the
actual lens of the camera is and then
you also need to match the rotation and
the field of view of the camera so other
than that it should work with any recent
build of unity unity is a framework for
building 3d stuff that a lot of
programmers use and because the system
ties into it the mixed reality lab can
work with a lot of different VR games
not all of them but a lot I'm because
the tracking on the HTC vive is so
accurate we can do things like go in for
a close-up on the laser gun that I
reckon I'm holding right now granted
there's a vibe controllers sticking out
of the middle of it but the positioning
is pretty much perfect when you're
playing in VR normally all the computer
needs to output is the view that you see
in
headset when we're doing mixed reality
we also output the view as seen from
this third controller this virtual
camera and so what that gives us is four
views instead of just the one the four
views are yes the headset view as usual
we also see the background as seen from
the perspective of this virtual camera
and then we have two layers of
foreground one of them is the image
itself everything that should appear in
front of the player and then we have
just a luma layer to help yukio
the black space the steamvr plug-in
automatically selects the foreground and
the background based on the position of
the headset and anything that is between
the headset and the third controller its
foreground and anything that's beyond
the headset becomes background here in
our studio we're doing a live composite
on the fly and this is a rough idea of
what you'll get in your final edit the
live composite is a bit rough around the
edges but you can also take the original
assets and do a much more detailed
composite in post-production later now
virtual studio is on - you think the BBC
have been using one for election night
for years although it uses carefully
prearranged graphics lots of expensive
broadcast quality equipment and the host
has to rehearse and hit all their marks
exactly for things to look right and
let's face it replace this headset with
a helmet of justice and you've got 1992
British kid Joe nightmare all those were
fancy custom-built Affairs though this
uses more off-the-shelf components if
you want to do this at home you're going
to need a large wraparound green-screen
but you could paint your walls you're
going to need a very powerful computer
you'll need a camera that can feed a
signal back into your computer you're
going to need a capture card and third
controller but if you have all of those
things you can build a mixed reality
setup at home thanks to everyone at
YouTube space New York and the mixed
reality lab you can find out more about
them are the links in the description
yeah nice all right that's good
[Music]
that's a wrap